science may be able to help us find
happiness during this difficult time
professor Laurie Santos created the most
popular class at Yale University was
called it is called rather psychology
and the good life in her podcast the
happiness lab she offers solutions for
keeping our spirits up during the
pandemic she joins us now from New Haven
Connecticut from her home there good
good to see you again professor Laurie
Santos listen you know what I think
again a lot of people are being anxious
we're really glad to see you a lot of
people are feeling anxious they're
feeling stressed and they're looking for
help
Laurie help and if the if the new
applications at that headspace
meditation app or any indication a lot
of people are trying meditation for the
first time we all know of course that
that works you know when you do it when
you do it correctly it actually works
so other than meditation talk about the
importance of that what other tools do
you have in your toolkit to help us out
during this time you know I think
meditation is a really fantastic tool I
mean the research really suggests that
it can allow you to stop ruminating
because you're doing such a great job of
focusing on say your breath or a mantra
but part of why meditation so helpful is
it really allows you to take some deep
breaths over time and the way that works
is it allows us to kind of curb our
sympathetic nervous system that's the
fight-or-flight response we're all going
through right now it allows us to kick
in the parasympathetic response which
gets us back to rest and digest which is
what all of us need right now I still
got to figure out though how to quiet
your mind because you start meditation
then it goes off in 50 million
directions because you're thinking about
other things what else do you have in
your toolbox what does the science say
about other things well the biggest
thing that the science says is that we
need to make time for social connection
you know social distancing can be a time
where we feel a little bit more lonely
but it doesn't have to be with
technologies just like the one we're
using right now we can reach out across
time zones across neighborhoods to talk
to the folks we really care about and we
need to do that in a really informal way
not just the kind of official sort of
work type chats that we do online but
all the kind of informal things you know
do
with a neighbor next door online you
know try to try to have a dinner across
different time zones with friends I've
been doing that with friends in Seattle
and it's been fantastic laureates
Anthony I wanted to ask a former student
of yours created a website called
invisible hands which is helping deliver
a groceries to the elderly can how does
doing something like that helping other
people help your own state of mind yeah
well this is a kind of a misnomer in the
current culture we think what we need to
do right now is to double down on
self-care or treat yourself but actually
the research suggests that focusing on
other people can improve our well-being
- and that winds up being a win-win you
know if you take time to a call an
elderly neighbor or donate that money
you're saving on your daily latte to a
good cause right now you're not just
helping those other good causes and
helping people who are vulnerable you're
also helping yourself you're getting a
little boost of well-being yourself
through that act of doing something
really nice for others so it's a huge
win-win hey Lori one of the things I
like to annoy my children with is the
the montt the adage that you can't
always change the world but we can
always try to change our perspective or
our relationship to the facts on the
ground and you spoke to a philosopher
who provided similar advice about how a
shift in perspective can really alter
our attitudes can you talk us through
that relationship between perspective
and how we feel about the facts as they
are yeah I think you know one of the
striking things about this crisis is
there's a lot we can't control you know
we can't stop the virus we can't control
how long we're going to be you know
trapped in our houses but there's one
thing we can control which is our
mindset you know we can control whether
we're gonna panic in the context of this
crisis we can control whether we see it
as say a challenge to be fought in one
rather than some sort of crisis and in
talking with philosophers like Bill
Irvine the ideas that you can use those
different mindsets to feel better you
know if you walk into the next week
thinking you know this is a challenge
and my family and I are gonna kill it
you know we have our game faces on we
are ready for this you'll be incredibly
more resilient than you would be if
you're kind of woe is me and facing this
as a crisis so just a subtle shift in
your mindset can be incredibly important
for how you feel but also how you get
through this crisis in terms of your
decision-making let's talk about
relationships
because now that we are forced to be
together 24/7 for a lot of couples
that's either really good or really bad
what does the science say about stress
and relationships and how to navigate
that well I think the science says that
this is a real thing you know just
validating that this is incredibly hard
to be running a daycare and a
babysitting service and your job with
your partner you know it's a lot of
stuck in a house sometimes enduring
crises relationships get worse you know
we see things like divorce rates going
up during hurricane sandy but we also
see marriage rates going up and and
birth rates going up which means people
are you know doing the things they need
to do to make babies and so what that
science tells us is there are good and
bad things we can be doing in
relationships and one thing we can do is
to try to double down on the positive
things you all of us have something
that's great about our relationship
whether we share humor together or work
well with the kids together this is the
time to figure out what those things are
and find ways in your current situation
to double down on the positive stuff all
good advice Laurie Santos sometimes it's
good just to work in different rooms if
you can do that that's what I'm doing
here it's our surviving season two of
the happiness lab will be available
April 27th on podcast platforms Laurie
thanks again